cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com well let's jump to this
story from timcast.com Washington Post
downplays Its Own poll that shows Trump
beating Biden by 10 points the poll
found 56 Americans disapproving of
buying take a look at this I'll just
jump right to 538
the last two polls we have from ABC News
and the Washington Post show Trump is up
10 points and nine points I love this
because if you even go back to last week
you do it Biden does have a poll right
here against Trump he's up too but
you've got Trump up three in this one up
five up three it looks like and what do
we have one of them's big one of them's
got like six thousand uh morning console
no these are older ones yeah I guess uh
they must change this a lot talking
about this earlier you've got this one
from September September 15th 2500
people trumps up one point
let's go back here 3 000 registered
voters Harris X Trump is up five yeah so
they they did change this from what I
was reading earlier but uh you can see
basically when it's not Trump when it's
junk in DeSantis when it's Haley uh
actually Haley beats Joe Biden while
surprising
but you can see that Trump's winning
that's it we did not have this in the
2020 cycle so if it would stand to raise
it at the election were held today Joe
Biden loses
but how's he doing in the in the crucial
States though
um uh I I don't know that's a good
question I can say that this poll also
found among Independents Trump is up I
think like 11. so that matters
independent voters matters for the swing
States but the swing States themselves
it's a more important question
individually I think Trump just needs to
win what does he need like Arizona
Georgia and Wisconsin or something yeah
good luck
because that's not even a question of
sentiments and a question it's a
question of procedure Trump's going to
need to overcome massive procedural
biases against him with these states I'm
not surprised that these poll numbers
everybody that I talked to they would
take Trump over Biden any day but I am
surprised that the Washington Post
actually released it and that kind of
gives me a little bit concern because
maybe they might start putting these out
to kind of put the narrative in that oh
the Democrats need to replace Joe Biden
because everybody's been talking about
he'll eventually be replaced but we
don't know how it's going to come I
don't see him just stepping down so they
might try to take him out with some sort
of Scandal or maybe they just start
highlighting actual polls and say
actually Biden's not doing too good we
got to get somebody out of there I think
you're totally right I think a lot of it
is the Washington Post uh acknowledging
that at least within their internal
structure there is they are questioning
Joe Biden and this comes right it
coincides with the date that they set
for the DeSantis Newsom debate right so
that's November 30th now we know that
there are people who would like to see a
DeSantis Newsome 2024 uh race that
that's what they ultimately want
I think that there there is no clear way
I mean we've talked about it a fair
amount on the show there's no clear way
for them to just swap out Biden for New
Summit would be sort of a dramatic
production but there is enough
bifurcation within the party that they
they don't know that they actually want
to see Biden there there's another poll
that came out today I think the company
called Harris X that found uh you know
among voters Biden is ahead but Kennedy
is consistently gaining ground uh Robert
of Kennedy Jr is consistently gaining
ground people are interested to him and
then there is a huge portion of Voters
even among registered Democrats uh you
know 16 at least that say that they
would want someone else they aren't
happy with you know Marion Wellington
RFK Jr or Biden but they also
don't know who would be there I mean you
get you see that there is sort of a a
rumbling to see if maybe someone else
would would step up
um I don't know it's crazy I mean RFK Jr
has initially came out I think around
five percent and he's consistently
climbed he I'm seeing him pull
consistently well yeah
and I think uh they've just lost control
of the machine right
they can't do anything about it if Biden
was the best they could muster the
screwed
yeah
but they don't have a clear way to
handle getting rid of him and I think
I've always thought it was that Biden
himself wants to stay for as long as
possible why would he want to step down
he's I I in my opinion it obviously in
ill health uh and so that's why you
would get his press secretary saying oh
well he's still considering what to do
even when Biden had made statements
saying no I intend to run again uh this
went on for a long time it was sort of
strange and then he sort of rolled out
this video campaign discreetly he
announced to be a video that he was
going to run for a second election or a
second term I think it wouldn't be the
case if they really felt he was in a
strong position in terms of his policies
and his health I think that they would
celebrate him as the incumbent if they
if they really believed in him and the
Democratic party doesn't
yeah so there's been more and more
obvious every day it's like there's
eventually going to be a point like
Tim's talked about how Newsome comes and
saves uh Biden passing out on stage or
something like that there's going to be
a point where it's going to happen and
it's just going to take like a couple a
couple more polls that are indicated
right that you know for us I guess you
could say us and we would like seeing
Trump ahead of him just a couple more so
yeah we're like right there I think
we're seeing a repeat of um uh uh who am
I thinking of uh the Supreme Court
Justice who everyone wanted to step down
and then she didn't
um oh uh Bader Ginsburg yes thank you uh
when Ruth Bader Ginsburg was was they
were trying to time it so that a
Democrat could appoint her and there
were a lot of people who said she stayed
too long and then ultimately uh died
when Donald Trump was in office and that
was such a disaster I think in some ways
Biden is going to do the same thing
which is he really should step down and
he said you know all sorts of things
when he was running he made it overtures
as if he would be a one-term president
but he was really sort of here to defeat
Donald Trump and obviously now ego
before everything else he doesn't want
to give up his seat or at least the
powers that have kept him in his don't
want him to go uh I think Trump wins
2024. yeah easily I mean I don't know
about it easily I think there's gonna be
a lot of crazy that happens but I just
think
narratively Trump's gonna win who do you
think is uh
Elon Musk Elon musk's adage right the
most entertaining outcome tends to be is
it what elon's razor or did someone else
come up with that that's someone else's
quote isn't it the most entertaining
outcome tends to be I thought it was
Elon Musk but maybe he's just uh passed
it off I just can't imagine a world in
which we don't get another term of
Donald Trump
I just don't know but like all the
pieces lined up on the chessboard Biden
I mean to be fair a a Biden presidency
is also comical you know what I mean
like at this point in his life seeing
like the president wheeled out to the
podium in a wheelchair with a burlap
with a little blanket on his lap and
he's like and you're like hey you know
spicy it's a comical but costly I don't
know that we could actually do it who do
you think Vice the vice president if who
do you think Trump's gonna pick as a
vice president because I feel like his
vice president's actually going to be
sort of important I mean given
everything Christina yeah
yeah you guys really think that a
republican can can win
in 2024 given how the electoral process
has changed since covid
yes those changes by 42 000 votes
in 2020. yes but in my opinion the way
elections are Iran uh in many states
that systematically disadvantages
Republicans of course it does but Trump
only lost by 42 000 votes the advantage
Democrats had with universal mail and
voting was everyone's locked inside
their homes and they couldn't leave they
don't have that Advantage anymore so
they'll need something and we've had
other elections since since
um November 2020 and it hasn't really
turned out that well for Republicans
because Republicans are only just now
starting to wake up to the issue and
again we're talking about an electoral
system where Trump lost by 40 000 votes
in three states which could easily be
made up versus individual members of
Congress and key districts where we were
like wow we're surprised they did not do
better well yeah I mean in Lauren
bobert's District she came really close
to losing my favorite thing about that
is as soon as she pulled out slightly
her opponent I think fresh was his name
was like no no recount no recount like
what do you mean no no let's let's go
through every single bow with a
fine-tooth comb well I think the issue
is universal mail and voting did play a
role it does benefit Democrats but
demographics shift because of covid that
benefits Democrats but the issue really
comes down to do Democrats have the same
Edge the first time around is Joe Biden
building confidence and we're talking
about one man at a national level and
not individual members of Congress
because what we did see is that you
you're likely you're likely to get and
this happened in 2018 as well if you
were a Democrat but moderate elected
there were 31 moderate Democrats that
were like we don't want to fight with
Trump we want to focus on Health Care
your wages things like that for you guys
you know unions we want to work for you
guys and so they voted for these dudes
that moderate message Works people care
more about kitchen table issues than
they do about anything else
now the issue is with Trump
okay at the local level you know that
you can vote for a Democrat you know the
guy he's got a much you know it's a
smaller constituency and maybe you talk
to him and you trust them but you've
known that fouries of Biden has been
really really bad so you're like you
might you'll probably get a lot of
Independence they're going to be like
yeah maybe vote for a Libertarian
Democrat or some middle position but
then vote for Donald Trump for president
because that's the Practical solution
so yes can Donald Trump win yeah he only
lost by 42 000 votes yeah how could he
not win like that's that that's that
that's probably like a million bucks and
spending on ads they could have done to
get Trump those those ballots yeah and I
think in 2020 Trump was kind of looked
at as the villain uh amongst Democrats
and even now uh going into 2024 he's
kind of fondly missed people missed the
days of trump and they're not so angry
at him because they didn't have to deal
with him every day for four years I
don't think it's going to be the same
outcome as 2020. yeah I think there's
also a lot of people that have watched
the outcome of what their their choice
was in The Ballot Box and I've seen what
the result of there's been there's
people in interviews all the time saying
I voted for about unless I'm not going
to vote for him this time and they feel
they're more like Tim always says you
say like would crawl through broken
glass or vote for Trump I feel like
they're almost amazing yeah exactly yeah
but there are more people that are like
that but I think there's a lot of people
that are just like I ain't crawling over
glass for anybody and I'm out yeah
people people voted against Trump and
all that those things got worse and now
we're at War and they're probably just
like do you think voter turnout will be
particularly
particularly low in 2024 sorry I'm
stuttering today I don't know what how
what was it last time right I thought it
was going to be really high in 2020. I'm
not sure I didn't think it was high it
was high among young people yeah that's
largely because of male and voting right
I think I think it was the uh it was
super high yeah I thought it was going
to be super high and then uh
what do we have here voter turnout in
I mean it's hard it's hard to say
because population growth hmm yeah oh
wait no look at this voter oh this is a
percentage of voter turnout this is
amazing in uh let's say 1800 voter
turnout was seven percent
no wait what U.S presidential election
popular vote totals is a percentage of
the total U.S population wow
that is insane
yeah that's yo in in 1912 voter turnout
was under 20 it was 18 17 this looks
like yeah 17 no wait 16 percent
wow
yeah I'm impressed and that's turned out
over total population though 16 of the
US population population voted for the
uh voted
in the presidential election in 1912.
so today we got 50 that's not bad man
you look at even during the Civil War
nobody was Voting nobody cared that's
crazy
I mean a lot less people could have
voted too
percentage-wise well I'm just saying
you're saying voting was restricted so I
wonder like what the turnout is well
there you go amongst uh registered
voters right yeah it doubles in 1928.
women love going out to do things that
that looks like that's about it like uh
just shy 20 suffrage happens and it's
just shy of 40 so it looks like it's
slightly more than doubled and now uh
since then it's gone slightly it's been
trending upwards
yeah not this only goes to 2016 by the
way but I'm pretty sure 2020 was the
biggest
81. yeah people are like 81 million
votes were buying that didn't happen I'm
like they were mailing out balance to
people's home right so it wasn't turnout
it was uh voter participation yeah
we'll see what happens I think it'll go
down in 2024 actually I'm curious on
that in California do you see lots of
political signage already like I know in
parts of West Virginia the Trump signs
went up in 2016 and have stayed the
whole time do you see Pro Biden signs
like what what are you seeing on the
ground where you live
I can probably say that I've never seen
a pro Biden sign
um even after Biden won some of my
neighbors still had their Trump flags up
the Trump flags and signs were going up
for a while you know kind of in protest
um but I see F Biden shirts or
um let's go Brandon was a lot there's
nobody who's really motivated for Biden
just from what I've seen yeah what was
the um
the let's go brand and stuff that blew
up
wave of not even technically
pro-trump just anti-violence I tweeted
about this the other day um it's still
kind of an anti-trump sentiment I was
pulling into a parking lot and I see a
guy he's got a sticker on the back of
his car says Trump 2024 my window was
down so I was almost gonna say yo like I
see you bro but I get closer it's Trump
20 to 24 years in prison
oh
faked you out I wish
right like I know I don't like that guy
uh I find that interesting because I
I've always like lived in more
liberal-leaning areas where if you like
any kind of conservative or libertarian
you tend to keep it to yourself but
every once in a while you'll be
somewhere and you'll see there's one
house on the Block that is like I don't
care I'm putting up my political science
and they're typically 45 pro-trump signs
there's this one house that I pass in
the area that'll have this flag of like
Trump standing over Eagles and like you
know he's like just like a caricature
but there are there's no equivalent for
Joe Biden there is maybe vote Joe Biden
because you like the Democrats but
there's not this same sort of belief in
his capabilities in my opinion and I
think that's just because people voted
for Joe Biden because they wanted to get
Trump out he was he was the anti-trump
guy they weren't necessarily so gung-ho
about Biden they just didn't like Trump
that much that they would vote for Biden
to get Trump out so they're not
incentivized to waive the Biden Flags or
buy some Biden merch in the same way
that pro-trump voters were mm-hmm
they're definitely a lot of super fans
they're not like the Trump base that's
for sure right even like I remember
there was a lot of Obama merch back in
the day and he had a mad hype Hillary
Clinton she had a bunch of stuff I'm
with her H is all everywhere yeah
um but I mean Dubai's never captured
that attention any of the times he's run
for president no no way thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time